i'm a big fan of his work and appreciate
his calling in uh critical thinking
opens in virtual cinemas vod
and digital today uh the star and
director of this film is feature film
directorial
debut uh critical thinking is the name
of the film john leguizano
long john leguizamo here on the rich
eisen show how are you john
david don't hurt yourself saying my name
you know what i i
i should have been more hydrated for
that john but uh
normally i stick the landing a little
better for that
hey john thanks for calling into the
show and congrats on this film
um before we get to that i do want to
talk a little bit of sports with you
uh are you a met fan is that a true
story yeah yeah you know that i'm from
queens
meds it's so sad to lose tom this week
tom seaver
uh you know painful uh i have some
some baseball cards from back in the day
three of them still left with me from
you know in the shoe box
underneath my bed and what not uh yeah
matt's fan big big time
so um does that make you a jet fan too
john because uh they used to play in the
same stadium and
we're of the similar age that that those
usually i wanted to be
i wanted to be mets jets and nets right
i can't
i can't i'm still a knicks fan
regardless of dolan and whatever he does
uh you know well and i'm a
and yeah i'm jets i'm jets
right okay um so what are your memories
of seaver
john what are your what are your
memories of tom terrific who passed away
at 75
this week wow i mean mostly baseball
cards i got
i got to be honest that was mostly my
thing was
flipping those baseball cards with tom
seven you know everybody fighting for
the tom severa card you know of course
then we used to have to flip him on the
ground and whoever his colors match he
took the the pile i totally remember
that
but i would never flip siever i would
usually say here's ed cranepool
you know i wouldn't want you know i'd
usually do that
that would be or jerry grote is catcher
usually would be the one that i would
flip because thomas
you must have a lot of bubble gum money
because i didn't have that much bubble
gum
i had whatever i had bubble gum mummy
money i love that that's fantastic
um so uh your your film critical
thinking
opening today in virtual cinemas vod and
digital tell everyone about it
and uh and know why you decided to take
this up as your first uh
directorial gig uh well you know
it's a true story an incredible true
story of five
latin and black kids from that one of
the toughest neighborhoods in miami
called overtown liberty city back in the
day
who became champions of miami then
regional champs
all over the state finally state champs
and eventually
united states national chess champions
true story uh this teacher mary martinez
i went to florida i met with him
fell in love with the guy i mean he was
all in unconditional
about as much he would do everything for
these kids to get him
to to to win a prize because they were
talented gifted
intellectual but their schools were
defunded you know there's no
trickle-down
economy that doesn't exist that's bs
let's let's face it
and and they didn't have supplies they
didn't have money for
for the class and this teacher with the
kids raised all the money himself
and and got them to be champions of the
united states
and uh a true story again from 1998
um and it's just again it's a it's a
beautiful story i i had not heard of it
to be very honest with you i had not uh
i did not
know about this what did you learn no i
i didn't either bro i got to be honest i
i didn't know about it either it came to
me it was offered to me to to be the
protagonist to star
as a teacher and then they offered me to
direct it because they saw
my passion for the project and obviously
it wasn't based on my chest skills thank
god
i wouldn't have got it right because i'm
an amateur dilite
that's for sure nice uh but you know i
had the real guys they're about 40 now
and i had them on the set every day and
i had rehearsals and i said you know it
if it looks like we're faking it you
know like in some movies you see like
people playing baseball and you know the
way they hit they hit that bat you know
it doesn't look real
i didn't want that with the chest
because there is a certain swag
and a certain like what walk me through
the chest swag john
what's the chest swag what do you have
you got to be able to throw it down
with three fingers and it's got to land
you got to fling it and it can't top it
can't topple over it can't lean on the
other guy
on the rook or on the or on a on a
knight or a bishop it's gotta
just land there and then when you wanna
crush somebody you you grind it into the
plastic board
that's the swag that you're talking
about i did not know that either
oh yeah dude it took hours because my
boys were trying to do it
and the pieces would fly across the room
they
missed the square and i think i got i
was like my brothers
you're going to make me look bad you're
going to make yourselves look bad more
more than that
you better carry a piece with you all
day long and just slam it
a hundred million times till you can do
it without looking
so again it's it's funny how you say
that uh you know that uh
this is just like any i guess in a way
sports movie that you don't want to have
anybody who's an
aficionado of the sport say that that
doesn't look real
what is your favorite sports movie john
leguizamo
who's yours i had a boy it's just
i don't know that movie gets to me every
single time it was dennis hopper's
comeback
uh i don't know it's just it killed me
we had the director of the movie uh
uh david onsbach on a couple of months
ago john
and he told me i said what was it like
to get gene hackman you have to twist
his arm to do the movie
he said hackman on the set
um thought the movie was going to be a
total flop
oh no i know and that the scene if you
remember the montage
where things are beginning to cook well
for hickory and that dennis hopper's on
the bench
with hackman and they're laughing david
said that the scene that he kept that in
the that in the movie
not knowing that the reason why hopper
was laughing
was hackman said to him as they were
rolling that uh after this movie comes
out that they're going to have
no careers left
[Laughter]
i don't mean to ruin it i love i love
cynical stars like that man
i love that that's what he said you got
you got to talk
trash about your work you can't take
yourself so damn seriously you know what
i mean
sure so what do you get the most john
when you're walking around
from from it depends you know i i could
tell about a lot about you
by the movies you pick like my lgbtq
community always says
two wong fu teaching rodriguez my
hoodies always say you know carlito's
way an empire
italian people don't get mad at me for
carlito's way they're like hey why'd you
have to kill pacino he was going to get
away and i'm like hey hey
it's not a documentary it's a it's a
it's a made-up
movie okay still alive you can see them
anywhere uh
and uh and all the cinephiles always go
summer sam spike lee's flick
that's yeah that was something else what
about house of bugging john
what does that say about me if i if i
say that
i guess i get some love you know it's
always like people in the in the in
their late 20s early 30s who remember it
you know barely but they go oh man i
wish i could i still had that vhs
i love it hey john i appreciate the call
congrats on critical thinking
it's a big hug it's a beautiful movie
everybody should check it out virtual
cinemas vod and digital critical
thinking john leguizano of the star yeah
stay healthy and safe for me
back at you the star and director of
that that's uh that's john right here on
the show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here